the u.s capitol is still reeling from
this attack
a car careering into two police officers
before smashing into the barricade
a man then jumped out brandishing a
knife before he was shot
he since died from his injuries and has
now been named as 25 year old noah green
from indiana police are still trying to
establish the motive
but they don't believe at this early
stage that this was terrorism
related the investigation is ongoing
from what we can see
from video at this time i do not see
the suspect wrestling with a u.s capitol
police officer
but when he exited the vehicle the knife
was clearly
in his hand and he did start to run
toward the officers
this entrance is one of several
accessing the u.s
capital complex and it's primarily used
by senators and their staff
although congress is currently in recess
[Music]
staff and journalists who were inside at
the time were warned to stay away from
windows
and seek cover security is still very
tight here at the capitol buildings the
center
of the united states government now
investigators are still
carrying out their forensic work trying
to understand
exactly what happened but what is
already clear is that after the events
of january the 6th
this has been another traumatic day for
the police
one of the police has now died from his
injuries and has been named as william
evans
a serving officer for 18 years i ask you
to please keep the united states capitol
police family
in your thoughts and prayers at this
time it has been an
extremely difficult and challenging year
for
us but we will get through this and we
do appreciate the community support
the president joe biden has reacted
expressing his heartfelt condolences to
his family
and sending his gratitude to all those
who responded to the attack
washington d.c has been on high alert
for the last few months
following this the storming of the
capital building
by donald trump supporters rallying to
his false claims
that the presidential election was
stolen
the security services warned that
further unrest could follow
in america's febrile political
environment
people carry out acts of violence that
phenomenon
sadly does not seem to be going away
anytime soon
there are some complex reasons for that
the pandemic being one of them
but sadly um most experts including
our own government's recent intelligence
assessment that was released about two
weeks ago
suggests that we should continue to
expect to see
actors usually alone or in small groups
conducting acts of violence like this
security will remain high here in the
days to come
but once again this is a city in
mourning
coming to terms with another attack on
its center of power